joining me now is stephen miller former
senior advisor to president trump
founder of america first legal and also
ben domenic editor-in-law of large at
the spectator and fox news contributor
stephen um
do you think that they were
trying
to hobble her early on when they gave
her the border assignment
i think they knew early on what we've
all figured out which is that she is
horrendously incompetent totally useless
has the speaking skills at best of a
first grader if you're being generous
and has absolutely no ability to do
anything useful whatsoever and since
they knew
very sick but they knew that the border
was going to be in a never-ending state
of crisis they figured they might as
well leave that on her even though of
course we know that joe biden and his
whole administration have the entire
board of disaster on their hands and
conscience now ben in politico today
they say that harris plots her next move
more aggressive volley in the abortion
rights arena i mean is that going to
catapult her into i guess being as close
to richard nixon and intellect and
historically laura what you don't
appreciate about this moment is the
importance of the passage of time
passage of time at the center of our
understanding of the vice presidency
look you know you can
assign the vice presidency to being a
warm bucket of spit but as you look at
the various vice presidents who have
held this role over the years many of
them have been very important in terms
of assisting the president that they
have worked with
including richard nixon including his
role for dwight eisenhower but when it
comes to kamala she's not just
unimportant to this administration she
is the grab bag for everything that they
don't want to deal with including the
border including all of these other
things that are supposed to be on her
portfolio but that she's not going to
deal with no one has faith with her in
her as being a potential replacement for
joe biden and as it becomes clear that
he is someone who is completely
incapable of fulfilling the role of the
presidency and that 2024 is just looming
on the horizon you're going to see more
and more democrats start to question her
start to try to figure out how can we
possibly replace her in terms of the
next person to step up i think that's
right and look people are always talking
about well is it going to be trump or
some other person desantis and there's a
fight between the establishment the
populace and yeah that's true so
republicans have a challenge to try to
figure this all out but they have a real
they have biden can't run nobody wants
them and nobody wants kamala so guess
who's next well here's our secretary of
transportation diving into the hot
button issue of guess is this
transportation watch
our marriage deserves to be treated
equally
and i don't know why this would be hard
if they don't want to spend a lot of
time on this
they can vote yes and move on and that
would be really reassuring for a lot of
families around america including mine
i mean you can't
turn the dial without seeing him on
every show like weekends he's seven days
a week on television so if they could
put kamala out there they would stephen
we have airline issues i mean not really
it is portfolio but we have baby food uh
shortages still change yeah supply chain
the but we have a big thing going on at
the at the ports in california and this
guy's about well let's talk about me
this is unbelievable we've got the
supply chain crisis we have the airline
crisis we have the infrastructure crisis
and all they can do is put pete out on
tv to either a talk about his own
marriage or b talk about how roads in
america are racists and our bridges are
bigots but is he their plan z
he's playing f g h i mean who knows how
far down the list he is their team their
roster is so incompetent look donald
trump would mow through all of them the
reality is is that whether it's biden or
harris or a buddha judge or newsome look
at the catastrophe of california crime
drugs homelessness pritzker look at
chicago the democrat party is in a
complete state of crisis because they
don't have one viable national leader
but ben they are never going to admit
that liberalism doesn't work right
they're not going to do that so they're
going to keep finding a slicker
messenger that's why newsom is kind of
rising to the top of the heap because
it's kind of slick you just have to
automatically uh raise somebody up if
they're if their teeth are that shiny i
mean it's one of these things where you
know you look at pete and it's like do
your hair like him yeah yeah i probably
should um but here's the thing when you
look at news when you look at pete what
you hear from him is so much leaning
into this kind of culture war animosity
that says you know republicans are
bigots well you know guess what when
barack obama ran for president he was
someone saying that marriage was between
a man and a woman it was donald trump
who was coming along and and being the
first president to say actually you know
i'm okay with this so maybe you should
recycle this kind of uh bigotry this
kind of uh approach to uh culture war uh
dynamics uh through reality in order to
understand that actually we really more
care about whether you are delivering on
what your job is for americans as
opposed to engaging in this kind of hot
button culture war issue in order to try
to raise your hierarchy within this
ridiculous circumstance of replacement
for commonwealth they're grinding up
biden they're grinding up comma they're
going to grind through uh pete
butterjudge i think they're going to
keep going until they find someone who's
the better messenger for liberalism
stephen and ben so good to see you in
person both of you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else